le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
dans un contexte de graves difficultés
économiques et sociales et afin de
saisir la moindre opportunité de
favoriser la création d'activités et
d'emplois
le département a initié un projet de
valorisation des bel essai routier à
l'équipement à titre expérimental ainsi
été réalisés sur le parking du bras de
la plaine et sa mise à disposition a
fait l'objet d'un appel à projet qui a
permis l'installation d'une activité de
vente de produits artisanaux dans un
joli kiosque
comment est né ce projet où se situe ce
kiosque et quels produits y sont vendus
on en parle tout de suite non lien
social
le département a construit un kiosque à
vocation économique destiné à accueillir
une activité valorisant nos savoir faire
locaux ce qui permet à la fois de créer
de l'emploi et de procurer un service de
proximité
la parcelle retenu pour ce kiosque que
se situe sur le parking du pont du bras
de la plaine ouvrages d'art
exceptionnels dont le département est
propriétaire d aménagement d'aires de
pique nique avec kiosques et belvédère y
sont actuellement importés destiné à en
faire un véritable lieu de vie
plusieurs projets ont été déposés pour
l'exploitation de ce kiosque c'est
céline rodier bénéficiaire jusqu'à
l'heure du rsa qui va pouvoir exploiter
ce lieu et lui permettre de développer
son projet pour lequel elle s'est formée
aux questions d'hygiène et de sécurité
alimentaire et y vendre pâtisseries
fruits légumes produits artisanaux
tout cela pays bien sûr je voulais en
fait valoriser l'artisanat pays
et les productions locales j'avais déjà
dans les contacts poussés un papou
douceur notamment des producteurs qui
transformaient également leurs produits
et du coup quand je suis tombé en fête
sera une offre du conseil général qui
voulait ouvrir en fait un casque de
valorisation des produits pays je vais
renvoyer ma candidature qui est retenue
pour ouvrir ce site là je travaille
essentiellement avec des artisans des
producteurs du sud sauvage parce que je
reviens de saint-joseph donc une bonne
majorité des produits viennent de saint
joseph est un petit peu saint cloud
mais certains viennent aussi de l'ouest
tessin le d'autres un petit la hausse
pour le vin à une partie de mon verre
des mac
partout où je peux trouver des
productions de qualité et des
producteurs sont aussi intéressés est
prêt à proposer aussi leurs produits
dans ma boutique
ce qui m'a séduit c'est d'abord eux
la démarche de valorisation des produits
pays le point d'accès qui est quand même
sera un axe routier de passage même si
encore des difficultés pour faire
arrêter un peu les voitures pour attirer
en fait davantage de monde
et puis pas le loyer qui est quand même
relativement attractif par rapport à ce
qu'on pourra trouver pour une surface
équivalente ce que moi j'ai quand même
de saint-joseph va tous les matins donc
j'ai pas même les frais de déplacement à
prendre compte aussi avant j'allais sur
la plaine des grègues pourfendre défendu
mais comme maillon est là tout aussi
vois je crois que j c les avantages
c'est qu'il ya plein de produits
qu'on ne trouve pas mieux encore ils
font trop baissier sur le toit
il ya pas mal de
les trois îles au cours des confitures
des tirs auraient
vsf détente le pas mal de choix quoi
nous avons voulu donc ce site pour
qu'ils soient le plus attractif possible
à travers l'implantation ce kiosque qui
permet la valorisation donc il a un
double intérêt
bien évidemment la valorisation du site
du bras de la plaine qui permet de
pouvoir donc le promouvoir par
l'activité dont économique et
l'implantation de ce kiosque de produits
du terroir mais également permettre donc
à un public fragilisé puisque le porteur
de ce projet anciennement bénéficiaires
du rsa oeuvre aujourd'hui donc dans la
promotion du produit local
nous avons souhaité au département
depuis 2013 à ce que et bien la réunion
autour de l'activité économique à
travers son patrimoine puisse être
encore plus solidaire plus juste c'est
kiosque économiques sont de véritables
tremplins pour l'insertion et l'emploi
il valorise les sites sur lesquels ils
sont installés et permettent aux
touristes comme aux réunionnais de
découvrir et d'acheter des produits
locaux de qualité issus des producteurs
amoureux de la nature
cette offre économique sera par ailleurs
bientôt renforcés par l'installation
d'une entreprise de petite restauration
si vous passez dans le coin l'équipe des
lieux sera très heureuse de vous y
accueillir
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais